taking my front step from dero to hero
wasn't exactly on my bingo card this week
But once I start something I struggle to stop
and at this point of my life
I've given up trying to fight the impulses
and I just let them win
it certainly keeps life interesting
so I water blasted everything I could see
Potted a new plant for the front step
and things were starting to take shape
but I knew we were far from done
cause for some reason
I thought it would be a good idea to
paint my own front door mat
and it was significantly harder than I anticipated
but still heaps of fun
It would have been a lot easier if I'd made a stencil
but my printer decided it didn't wanna print
and it didn't wanna print because I didn't
wanna pay the subscription anymore
so despite the fact that I own the printer
and I own the ink
apparently I have to pay a subscription
every month just to use it
and that type of capitalism really fks me off to be honest
but that's the story for another day anyway
you've really got a layer the paint onto this
and I'm talking layers and layers
I tried to free hand a font and then I did a border
and I've added some flowers for a little bit of decoration
when it dries I'll spray it with a sealer
but while I was waiting I got distracted by shiny things
or rather the lack thereof
and I'm sure there are other people
out there that suddenly find themselves in
the middle of the most random task
but I noticed that all of the door hardware
was super dirty and aged looking
so I took to it with some barkeepers friend and a scrub daddy
and this combo always works wonders for me
it was taking years of her life like honestly
she was ageing backwards and by the time I was done
they were quite shiny and I was feeling quite
accomplished to be honest
and like yes
I probably could have gone out and just bought new hardware
and maybe one day I will
But I always say I don't mind if it's old so long as it's clean
and I personally get immense satisfaction
out of restoring something that's been in my
home for a long long time
hanging out with the door for so long was probably my downfall
because it was really hard not to notice all of the chips in the paint
and my toxic trait is that I gaslight myself into believing that a project
is gonna be a lot quicker and easier than it normally turns out to be
but it's that kinda delusion that gets shit done
so I'm not mad at it
side note but have you ever seen a woman sanding in her slippers
cause it was the first for me
and hopefully a last anyway
I sanded through the grades on the door and the door frame
and then I decided to paint cause why not
I was actually amazed to see how yellow the original paint was
compared to the new stark white that I was laying over
and with any project like this
it's really hard to know where to start and stop
so I did the entire frame inside and out
then it was time to turn my attention to the door
and I actually really like the blue
it just needs refreshing
There’s it's still a bit to do
so come back for the reveal